هذا منصه الكونجرس الامريكي لا تزال خاليه
من قائدها ثلاثه ايام عقيمه من المفاوضات
انتهت بعدم انتخاب رئيس جراء الانقسامات
في صفوف الجمهوريين ورغم ان النائب عن
ولايه كاليفورنيا هو الاوفر حظا لنيل
المنصب الا انه فشل في الفوز في 11 جوله
اقتراع مكاسي حاول تجاوز العقده وقدم
تنازلات كبيره لنحو 20 نائبا جمهوريا من
مؤيد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ممن
يعرقلون انتخابهم من بينها تسيل اجراءات
عزمي رئيس المجلس لكن التنازلات لم تجدي
النفعا فم مجموعه النواب هذه مصره على عدم
ثقتها بمكارسي وترفض الالتزام بقرار الحزب
ان هو المؤيدون ترامب وهم اعضاء في الجناح
الاكثر تحفظا في الحزب الجمهوري طلبوا
زملائهم بالانضمام لجبهه الاعتراض على
مكاسبه اصلاح النظام المعطل وفق تعبيرهم
هذه الفوض التي وصفها الرئيس الامريكي جو
فايدن بالمحرجه قد تستمر لساعات او اسابيع
مع عدم وجود منافس حقيقي لمكاسي علما بان
انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب بيتطلب غالبيه
218 صوتا امن منها مقاطع حتى اللحظه 200
فقط بالاضافه الى صوته سيواصل النواب
التصويت الى حين انتخاب رئيس للمجلس وهو
ما ذكر بما حدث عام
1856 حين لم يتفق اعداء الكونجرس على رئيس
الا بعد شهرين
وثلاثه وثلاثين دوره سيناريو لم يسبق له
مثيل منذ 260 عاما مجلس النواب دون رئيس
يعني عدم امكانيات تاديه النواب لليمين
وبالتالي العجز عن اقراري اي مشروع قانون